this mother accused of killing her own
child just outside of las vegas is now
in custody following a nationwide search
thank you for joining us here at four
o'clock
i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian goss
that as well this is a story many of you
have been following for nearly two weeks
now
after the body of seven-year-old liam
houston was found
the i-team's vanessa murphy joining us
in studio with more on the mother's
arrest this morning out of denver
vanessa
detectives are now interviewing samantha
moreno rodriguez as you mentioned she's
accused of
killing her own child police say they
believe she took his life here in the
las vegas area but
this case spans at least three states
nevada colorado and california
this is the mug shot for moreno
rodriguez the 35-year-old was taken into
custody at this hotel in denver
an arrest warrant was issued monday
after the remains of her son
seven-year-old liam houstead were
identified
that process took about 10 days and in
the meantime on june 1st
police say liam's father who lived with
the mother and child
reached out to the san jose police with
concerns he hadn't seen them
but he was hesitant and didn't want to
get the mother in trouble
lieutenant ray spencer described sort of
a dear john message the father received
on may 24th
and he says there was no indication the
mother would harm the child
she specifically tells him quote i'm
sorry i had to do it like this
she also goes on to say that i'm going
to try to get a house
for liam and i and that we can talk
about this in the future
there was nothing suspicious in that
message
that would lead the father to believe
that liam
or samantha was were involved in any
kind of foul play
or that there was any harm potentially
to come
the body of liam houstead was discovered
near a hiking trail in the las vegas
area on may 28th
again the father reached out to san jose
police on june 1st
then on june 4 a friend of moreno
rodriguez reached out to the san jose
police
pointing out that the sketch released
from police in las vegas
resembled liam the identification
process was fast tracked and
investigators say
that's how this case was solved samantha
moreno rodriguez is expected to be
extradited to las vegas
i asked police whether they believe liam
was the victim of
long-term abuse lieutenant ray spencer
says there's
no indication of that and now detectives
are working to try to find
a possible motive they have also not
released
how liam was killed
thank you vanessa we continue with team
coverage starting from the very
beginning that takes us to california's
bay area
police believe marina rodriguez left her
home in san jose with her son back on
may 24th
reporter rob fladeboy joining us live
now with the very latest from there hira
that's right kirsten san jose police
shared a few
new details about the case today as we
just heard
they say the first win they got in this
case was when the boy's
father notified them by phone back on
june 1st now keep in mind this is two
days
after liam's body was discovered he
calls police to report that he is
concerned
that his uh his partner and their son
are missing and he can't understand why
but again he says he does not suspect
any foul play he does not believe
there's any sort of criminal intent here
so he doesn't want to take it any
further than a missing persons case at
that point well
the real break in the case comes a
couple of days later
after police in vegas release a sketch
of liam
that another relative comes forward with
information that helps them
make the connection between the body
that was found on the trail
and the young boy missing here in san
jose more on that now from san jose
police sergeant
christian camarillo a friend of the
family
comes here to the police department and
makes us aware
of this sketch in las vegas she thinks
that sketch
looks like liam immediately you know
we connect that information with the
information we had from
june 1st and contacted las vegas metro
that got the ball rolling one of their
detectives came here to san jose
retrieved an item with some dna
and they were able to make the match
with liam
in las vegas
police here in san jose as well as in
las vegas i believe
say that the father so far is not
considered a suspect in this case
they did say though that based on that
message that
the father was left by samantha that
there may
possibly have been some marital discord
going on but they did also say that the
father is
cooperating fully with the case so still
a lot of moving parts here and a lot
left to learn
but that is the latest here in san jose
christian kirsten back to you
thank you so much rob we greatly
appreciate that clarification